[Music]
on this saturday night
a tale of two communities
the land dispute in ontario you never
relinquished title to this land never
once
the lobster fight in nova scotia the
quicker we could find some of the
solutions or some ways to de-escalate
the tensions the better that would be
the next steps for these growing
conflicts
bc votes will the mail-in ballots delay
the decision
plus donald trump casts his ballot along
with
millions of americans in what could be a
record and the soccer star's plea
to help kids in need
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the days are winding down to the u.s
presidential election
as that country reported its highest
ever daily total of covid 19 cases
setting a new record of 80 000
infections
in just 24 hours cases are spreading in
towns and cities in every region of
america
including remote areas that until now
had not felt the deadly force of the
virus
the pandemic is at the core of this
presidential campaign
and with just 10 days to go until
election day
many fear the worst is still ahead
jennifer johnson reports
in crucial swing state florida u.s
president donald trump took advantage of
early voting and cast his ballot
once again the president raised
questions on the safety of mail-in
voting
which millions of americans have done
amid the worsening covet 19 pandemic
it was a very secure vote much more
secure than when you send in a ballot i
can tell you that
yet in 2018 and in the 2020 primary the
president cast his ballot by mail
but the trump campaign feels mail-in
voting benefits democratic presidential
candidate joe biden
after polls showed roughly half of his
supporters would vote that way
experts tell us we're going to lose
nearly another 200 000 lives nationwide
in the next several months all because
this president cares more about the
stock market than he does you
the president is focused on reopening
the country as new cases of coven 19
increase in 41 states skyrocketing in
parts of the midwest
15 states are shattering new records for
hospitalizations
experts say precautions desperately need
to be taken
we're not talking about shutting down
but we're talking about doubling down
on some of the fundamental public health
measures
that we need to adhere to the universal
wearing of masks
the physical distancing even as the
death toll continues to rise dr fauci
says the white house coronavirus task
force
is no longer meeting daily just weekly
the association of american medical
colleges
is calling for a coordinated national
testing program
with routine testing we can find places
and find individuals who are infected
faster
and make sure we isolate them in
illinois a death toll approaching 9 500
people
brought the state's public health
director to tears these are people who
started with us
in 2020 and won't be with us at the
thanksgiving table
president trump keeps telling his
supporters the u.s is rounding the
corner
and a vaccine could be just weeks away
but public health experts dispute that
while issuing dire warnings the worst of
the pandemic
is still to come jennifer johnson global
news
washington the pandemic is top of mind
for many american voters right now
several states have expanded mail-in or
advanced voting for safety reasons
and americans are embracing the changes
more than 56 million have already cast a
ballot and that number is still climbing
our mike armstrong is in pennsylvania
tonight with a look at
what's driving people to the polls
all the jeeps are voting right now
that's right there is probably no better
way to gauge the interest
and passion around this election than
this a drive-through ballot drop-off for
early voting in york county pennsylvania
and a line that never stops
the idea here county officials say is to
make the process as
simple as possible watch me put it in
the box okay thank you
all set thank you the goal is
in this very busy day we live during a
pandemic
the more opportunities people have to
vote the better
the state for the first time has no
excuse early voting you don't need a
reason to cast a ballot before election
day
in fact they've sort of made it so easy
here there's almost no excuse
not to vote the heilemans dropped their
ballots off on foot
literally in seconds the applications
were sent out and when they came we
requested them and when they came and
there was concern about the covet and we
and so it was we felt i felt at the time
it was a safer option
yeah no this was painless now it was a
different situation in new york saturday
this was its first day for early voting
there were long lines sometimes meaning
weights of more than two hours
something people were willing to put up
with to have their vote counted
i mean for me personally i think this is
probably
the most important election of my life
anyway
this is the first time new york has ever
had early voting another example of how
american officials have tried to make
the process
easier and safer and it seems to be
working the u.s
matched its all-time record for early
voting days ago and the numbers are
still climbing
their estimates 85 million ballots could
be cast
early and then 70 million more on
election day that would mean voter
turnout
not seen in six decades it shows the
tremendous interest in this election
it shows the partisanship and the
polarization and how
how deeply voters feel thank you
thank you another thing all this early
voting means
is for a lot of people the decision has
been made and the ballots
cast the candidates can keep campaigning
but some people have already voted
and the polarization means a lot of the
people who are left
have already made up their minds ready
to vote mike armstrong global news
york pennsylvania it's election day in
british columbia
the ndp's john horgan is seeking a
majority mandate after three years of
running a minority government
it was a snap election because the ndp
government had until next year to call
it
more than a million people cast their
votes in advance including nearly 400
000
mail-in votes that had already been
returned as of yesterday
global bc's keith baldry joins us now to
break down
what's at stake so keith how did the
campaign go during a pandemic
very interesting of course it really
wasn't even a campaign in traditional
sense no rallies
no events no headquarters a few
candidates actually had
offices everything was done by telephone
uh the leaders tours
basically consisted of leaders showing
up in front of pool television cameras
uh with surrounded by maybe a handful of
people other candidates all wearing
masks and
basically one maybe two events a day so
it really was a non-campaign robin again
it
sort of sets the tone i think for future
elections in this pandemic
did john horgan's cam gamble though pay
off
right now it appears that it will be
when all the votes are counted
a number of polls including those done
for global from ipso suggests the ndp
has had a double-digit lead over the
liberals the nearest party
in contention since the pandemic began
public opinion hasn't shifted
this very much may turn out to be a
referendum on how the government is
handling
governing through a pandemic and
basically looking out for people and
right now
i think it's a positive thumbs up for
john horgan and the job he's been doing
he's been flying high in the polls on a
personal level far more than the other
alternatives notably bc liberal leader
andrew wilkinson who has not had a good
campaign and really has not resonated
well with the voters
but the wrinkle in all of this is the
mail-in ballots
yes indeed only 6 000 people a little
more than 6 000 people voted by mail
in the last election now we're probably
going to get in excess of a half a
million people voting by mail
that's extraordinary and it's going to
have an impact on how we call the
election tonight because by under bc's
election law
those potential 500 500 000 plus
ballots cannot be counted for two weeks
in close riding say less than a thousand
fifteen hundred
votes dividing two parties can we really
call a writing if there are six
seven in some cases twelve to eighteen
thousand votes
lying in envelopes that can't be counted
for two weeks uh worst case scenario we
don't know the outcome of this election
until mid-november hopefully we can call
it tonight but there is that scenario
that could play out where
we remain considered as suspended
animation for a couple weeks before
those mail-ins are counted
could be an interesting campaign and an
interesting election night thanks very
much keith
people living in saskatchewan are also
heading to the polls it's the final day
of advanced voting ahead of monday's
provincial election
saskatchewan has already set a new
record for the most advanced votes with
more than 150
000 ballots cast in just four days
election saskatchewan says that's more
than
in the past 10 general elections the
province is also seeing a record number
of vote by mail
registrations canada's top
doctor is warning the number of coveted
19 hospitalizations and deaths could
rise in the coming weeks because of a
spike in cases
dr teresa tam's comments come the same
day ontario is reporting a new
single day high of 978 confirmed cases
in quebec just over a thousand people
tested positive for the virus
in the last 24 hours and manitoba
recorded 153 new cases today
more than half are in the winnipeg
region
a massive coven 19 screening campaign is
underway this weekend at a quebec
meat packing plant the only male
slaughterhouse about an hour south of
quebec city
is dealing with an outbreak more than 80
employees have contracted coven 19.
one died a day after testing positive
for the virus
hundreds of workers are expected to be
tested this weekend
meat processing plants have had some of
the worst outbreaks
during this pandemic the federal
government is facing pressure over
indigenous rights on two fronts in nova
scotia
ottawa has appointed a special mediator
to facilitate talks
in what's been a tense standoff between
migma and non-indigenous commercial
lobster fishers
and in ontario protesters from the six
nations first nation
are standing their ground over
developments on what they say
are remains of their ancestral land mike
delay looks at the efforts to find a
solution
to these historic disputes
always peaceful in caledonia ontario the
roadblock remains as do the protesters
and down the highway the ontario
provincial police sit and watch the
latest in a dispute
that's been going on for centuries
this was video posted thursday when a
confrontation with police led to tasers
rubber bullets and more distrust within
an already fragile community
where is all the proof for the land
claims where is all
at issue is another development the six
nations protesters say is being built on
land
granted to them in 1784 as thanks for
their ancestors outlying with the
british
during the american revolution only five
percent of those lands remain in six
nations hands
we're not asking the federal government
for the deed we're certainly not asking
ontario
and we're certainly not asking aldermen
county
for the deeds of this land we have it
we've never relinquished title to this
land never once
another centuries-old treaty is at the
heart of a dispute over lobster in nova
scotia
at issue is a 21 year old supreme court
interpretation
of a treaty drafted in 1761 that
commercial fishers read one way
and indigenous fishers another the
disagreement has led to the equipment
being used by indigenous fishers
being vandalized and destroyed the
situation is so toxic
a federal mediator has been appointed
the quicker we could find
some solutions or some ways to
de-escalate the tensions the better that
would be
um to find a full final solution that
might take
more time and and will have to involve
more people
aleister surett has his work cut out for
him he has to navigate through decades
of animosity
similar to what the federal government
will have to do when it finally resumes
a dialogue in caledonia
says he plans on listening a lot
mike truly global news toronto
coming up how the american election will
affect canada's relationship
with washington
just one month into fall and bc has been
delivered an early and dangerous blast
of winter
the snowfall created chaotic driving
conditions in the interior
a number of crashes closed highways for
hours
kelowna received 13 centimeters of snow
which broke
a 120 year old record near cranbrook
heavy snow is being blamed for a head-on
collision
one person is dead another injured
crews in calgary were busy clearing
roads this morning
a snowfall warning calling for up to 20
centimeters of snow
has now ended in that city calgarians
are experiencing winter conditions on
the road
so 60 sand trucks were sent out to
reduce
slippery conditions the results of the
u.s
election will have an impact here in
canada this weekend on the west block
our mercedes
stevenson sits down with one of
president trump's former national
security advisers
mercedes what is john bolton's take on
current canada u.s relations
robin ambassador bolton has some
interesting insight into canada's
relationship
with the u.s i asked him what president
trump
thinks of prime minister justin trudeau
here's what he had to say
i don't think they have the smoothest of
relationships but i think it goes up and
goes down i think
trump's main interest throughout the his
presidency in canada was getting the
nafta trade agreement revised
that was successfully done not
everybody's terribly happy with the
outcome but at least the thrust of
nafta continues on national security
ambassador bolton says
china is the biggest existential threat
to western democracies
like canada we'll have more of that on
the show as well as an exclusive
one-on-one interview with seniors
minister deb schult
i had many questions on the federal
government's supports for seniors
particularly during the kovig 19
pandemic
are you concerned about seniors mental
health absolutely i mean the second wave
you just think
your heart breaks for these folks who
are in long-term care homes
it's emotional for me too can see it in
your eyes you have dementia
i mean i'll tell you why because i had
my mother-in-law
in a long-term care facility and she
passed away in june
so i am totally aware of the challenges
that families have had across canada
i've got my father-in-law in a senior's
residence and the challenges that he has
with us not being able to see him and
and the mental health
uh the strain of him losing his wife not
being able to see her
as she deteriorated because we weren't
able to be with her
so it is very emotional i'm emotional
too because i've i've
i've lived it and um and i hear the
stories and i'm on the phone
and i got the emails and i'm with people
every day that are struggling with this
issue and robin we did not forget about
that confidence motion we saw in the
house that almost triggered an election
political strategists of all stripes
join us to unpack
exactly how canada avoided a snap
election
all that and more is coming up on this
week's the west walk
robin all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa
a sad end to the search for a missing
new brunswick man who was a well-known
writer in the province's arts community
police in fredericton confirmed the body
of richard vaughn has been located
ten days after he was reported missing
he was last seen near his home on
thanksgiving
he was an author a playwright and poet
under the name
r.m vaughan and he served as the writer
in residence at the university of new
brunswick
friends and colleagues have also
described him as a mentor in the lgbtq2
community
von's death is not being treated as
suspicious he was 55.
still ahead the protest over a ban on
abortion in a country that
already has strict laws
you're watching global national
poland's president has tested positive
for covid19
in a country that reported more than 13
000 cases and 179 deaths
today andre duda has apologized to his
close contacts
who are being told to isolate the 48
year old says he has no symptoms
and is feeling good poland's president
joins a handful of world leaders who've
contracted covet 19
including the american president and
british prime minister
and tension is growing in poland tonight
over a new ban on abortions
thousands of demonstrators marched
across the country for a third straight
day of protests
on thursday poland's highest court ruled
that having an abortion
because of a defect was unconstitutional
the nation which already had some of the
strictest abortion laws in europe
will now only allow the procedure in
cases of rape
incest or when the mother's life is in
danger
the death toll from a suicide bomb
attack in the afghan capital
is expected to rise as crews dig through
debris
the explosion happened yesterday
afternoon at an education center in
kabul
in a predominantly shiite neighborhood
the attacker was trying to enter the
center when he was stopped by security
at least 18 people are dead and 57
others injured
but many families are still desperately
searching for their loved ones
up next the food fight over uk holidays
and school meals
hunger is a growing issue when school
breaks for holiday in the uk
students miss out on free meals provided
during school and families facing food
and security
rely on these programs to feed their
kids but the government blocked one
british athlete's attempt to extend the
program over school holidays
as crystal gomencing reports that has
sparked outrage
and compassion
it's nothing fancy just a sandwich
but it could be enough to stop a little
stomach
from rumbling i've been watching the
news and watching these stories and it's
been really sad
so i just thought right i'm going to
spend some money and feed some children
it's as simple as that ali waterworth
runs a children's charity
and cafe like many she was shocked when
boris johnson's government
voted down a labour party motion to
extend the school meals program
and offer families vouchers over the
half-term break
the government after all had seen the
value in extending it over the summer
months
saying families were battling added
pressures with the pandemic
it leaves me speechless if i'm honest
boris has got other things on his mind
at the minute and he's not doing it
as he should by the kids in my opinion
soccer star and poverty advocate
marcus rashford championed that
summertime meal program extension
he grew up in manchester and remembers
being hungry as a boy
despite having a hard-working loving mom
in rejecting this latest extension some
tory mps said it would create a
dependency on the state
and that the primary responsibility for
child welfare
rests with parents i know for sure that
a lot of them speak in the way that
they're speaking it's so insensitive
about the issue
and they've definitely not not been
through it themselves rashford and his
mom spent some time at a food share
food distribution center all the while
keeping up with his
online plea to feed hungry children
which led to this the young man's
twitter page now
reads like a giant takeout menu it is
filled with generous offers from little
shop owners to local town
councils all pledging to not let any
child
go hungry and then there are dozens of
tweets
reacting to the outpouring of kindness
the mayor of london
shared this post if you need a reminding
that our country is far
better and more generous than this
government
have a look at marcus rashford's twitter
feed this morning
as donations and accolades pour in
rashford watched his mom who once needed
help feeding her children
honored by having a food share warehouse
named after her
a moment to savor but not rest
rashford pledges to keep fighting and
giving a voice to those
who are struggling crystal gamson global
news
london and that is global national for
this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the early snowfall in prince george bc
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please send your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching and i'll see you back
here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]